people come to this house in the city of
Rawalpindi looking for a cure they think
demons are making them ill and come to
have them Wow my field is especially my
field is Giants black magic I am NOT
making black magic I destroyed the black
magic Cadoc tournament especially
doctors don't believe in a magically
that I can cure cancer he prescribes
verses from the Koran that are dissolved
in water along with a regular regime of
ritual exorcism yamna saludos been a
llorar con oh honey that's how he's
treating this 23 year old engineer wah
wah is present in his body Mohammed has
been coming here for two months I mean
there was you
me with your medals early man and there
was something came over me he says I
just lost control of my body automatic
he believes thousands of demons have
invaded his body he says they are to
blame for his complaints made more than
she looking my both club identity hard n
i suffer from various problems he says i
have constant headaches stomach pain and
other symptoms like that how to do go
I'm already gonna be good about that
looking out on the arm areas at first I
took medicine to try and cure them but
none of it helped me yeah exactly the
one on the mythology I'm beside with you
oh you're up Murr hamid and the other
patients here have complete faith in
this treatment and they have no desire
to visit a regular doctor you know the
psychiatric unit at this Islamabad
hospital cautions against consulting
so-called miracle healers head dr rizwan
Tosh regularly treats people who have
been to exorcists the bulk of patients
do not end up with us they are they
suffer they are not given proper
treatment and in some cases the
treatment the problem is worsened
because of this delay and because the
type of treatment that they be given he
believes the exorcists are only in it
for the money the mental health services
in Pakistan are quite deficient and they
are limited to the main cities and
because of that people would go to for
help to anyone don't attach his next
patient has consulted several exorcists
but none of them were able to cure her
schizophrenia